people would say all right yes the pound
dollar rate for example is back up to a
much higher level and so on there's
Merit to what you've just said but they
would say for example your pledge about
the boats the small boats coming over
they'd say not only not delivered this
situation is just seems to be getting
worse all the time and one of the key
things that brexit was supposed to be
getting control of our borders it seems
to be completely out of control what are
you actually going to do yeah about that
for example yeah so let's we'll take a
step back first of all why is that why
is that issue important to me because it
it is and it's a thing I spent an
enormous amount of time on it because
ultimately for me it comes down to
fairness and fairness really matters to
me and I don't think the current
situation is fair right people coming
here illegally it's not fair on those
who are working hard paying taxes
relying on public services it's not fair
on those who migrate here legally and
follow all the rules and it's actually
not fair on those who desperately need
our help from around the world and we're
not in a position to be able to help
them because of what's happening so for
all those reasons we need to fix this
and for me you know what what I hear
when someone says well you know if
someone comes here and claims Asylum
illegally they've come a really good in
the claim on this island I hear that so
that's wrong right when I hear that
someone has paid thousands of pounds to
come here and exploit our world-leading
modern slavery laws that's wrong or when
I hear that someone's trying to you know
game the system whether it's human
rights or exploit our compassion and
frustrate their removal to a safe place
like Albania or Rwanda that's wrong so
we have to fix all those things the
system that we need the system that I
want to introduce is one whereby if you
come here illegally you should be
swiftly detained and then in a matter of
days or weeks we will hear your claim
not months and years and then we will
safely remove you somewhere else and if
we do that that's how we'll break the
cycle because if all these Smugglers if
they see that that happens I understand
but I have heard this a lot my question
yeah so what are we doing we're going to
do to inform this yeah make it happen so
look in the first hundred days what have
we've done what have I done a I've got a
new deal with France which is increasing
the amount of patrols that are happening
on French beaches which is making a
difference already secondly I've got a
brand new deal with Albania
Albania accounted for a 30 of all the
illegal migrants of course that's
ridiculous but I've worked with the
albanians to put in place a new deal
which means for people coming from
Albania illegally we will be able to
remove them safely back to Albania and
that is already happening we're putting
illegal migrants from Albania back on
flight and that will ratchet up over the
year and that's tangible Improvement in
the situation that deal is a new deal
and then we're wholesale changing how
our Asylum system works in the UK to
make sure that we process things far
quicker and more efficiently we've got
more enforcement of people who are
working illegally but the key thing we
need to do is introduce new laws and
very soon we'll be introducing new laws
into Parliament which deliver the system
that I explained the system which says
if you come here illegally you're not
really going to be able to stay here
give me the simple explanation of what
this new law will look like so what that
law will say is if you come here
illegally for an illegal migrant here
then you will not be able to stay here
and in fact we will be able to detain
you and then we will hear your claim in
a matter of days or weeks not months or
years and we will have the ability in
the vast majority of cases to send you
to an alternative safe country be that
be where you've come from if it's safe
like Albania or indeed Rwanda that is
the system is Orlando ever going to
happen yes I mean we're working our way
through the courts with that and of
course they're going to be people who
try and frustrate this but that is a
system that I think the vast majority of
people watching will say that sounds
reasonable how do you couple it with
Humanity
how do you work out who are genuine
Asylum Seekers who who actually want our
help because they're desperate perhaps
from a war-torn country from a war that
we were involved in so there's a couple
of things a you're absolutely right but
that that is the bit that we have to get
right because we're always going to be a
compassionate country it's something
that we're all very proud of and that's
why drafting the law is is not
straightforward and we're taking the
time to get it absolutely right so that
we can capture those genuine cases which
of course we want to but the other thing
is this as we've demonstrated over the
past year or two when we need to open up
our hearts and our homes in this country
to those fleeing persecution whether
it's Afghanistan Syria Hong Kong Ukraine
we do and that's what being British is
all about but it needs to be done on our
terms so what I think actually is once
we've got a grip of the system and we've
largely stopped the flow of illegal
migrants we can have a much more
sensible conversation as a country in
saying well who do we want to take from
where and how many what's our ability to
help these people and actually have that
conversation proactively and work with
the Red Cross and the UN and others to
do that but first we've got to stop the
illegal migration have you told your
Home Secretary to dial down her rhetoric
which many people think has been overly
inflammatory and degrading in some cases
about migrants well I think that people
are frustrated with this situation I'm
frustrated with this situation but the
right way to deal with it is to do the
things that I'm saying and that's
required some hard work to get but on
language specifically well on language
look we should always remember that
we're a compassionate country right and
we've demonstrated that as I said with
Hong Kong Hong Kong Afghanistan Syria
Ukraine we're a compassionate country
she believes that everyone believes that
in the government and we've demonstrated
that as a country those are our values
but we're not a soft touch right we're
not a soft touch we believe in playing
by the rules We Believe In fairness as
well that is also equally British and we
need a system that delivers that and
that's the bit that we're going to fix